the road to freedom starts here Netflix
has just dropped the full-length trailer
for El Camino a Breaking Bad movie which
star a series favorite Aaron Paul back
in his role as Jesse Pinkman the film
picks up some time after Jesse made his
great escape from a band of neo-nazis
known as Jax white supremacist gang in a
stolen El Camino during the Breaking Bad
finale from there El Camino follows
Jesse as he attempts to evade
imprisonment and forge a new life bar
different from the one he experienced
alongside notorious meth cook Walter
white played by Bryan Cranston while the
trailer is jam-packed with a ton of
intriguing imagery returning characters
and a whole slew of teaser Eclipse it's
a short exchange near the end that has
our interest most piqued you ready so
who exactly was Jesse talking to at the
end of the El Camino trailer we have an
idea to us it sounds like the
disembodied voice belongs to Ed
otherwise known as that disappear oh the
vacuum cleaner repair man whom Walter
White called after Jax white supremacist
gang murdered his brother-in-law Hank
Schrader and Hanks partner at the DEA
Steven Gomez during season five after
Walt left his family behind it gave him
a new identity gathered all the
documents he needed to start with a
clean slate detailed how to get to a
safe house in New Hampshire and warned
him that he'd be caught and likely
killed if he left the premises
got two acres up here lots of woods nice
warm place seems to me just the spot for
a man to rest up thank God things that
is obviously an expert at giving
criminals new lives so it's not
unreasonable to think that Jesse might
seek the same service and El Camino
after all it isn't like Jesse and Ed
don't know about each other on season
five of Breaking Bad Walt's shady lawyer
Saul Goodman arranged to have Edie
disappear Jesse but Jesse backed out of
the plan in the eleventh hour maybe now
that he's truly desperate for freedom
Jesse will reach out to ed and ask for
help
however there's the chance that the man
is someone else with popular guesses
being the former crooked cop Mike
Ehrmantraut who is confirmed to be an El
Camino or Walter White himself however
the voice in the El Camino trailer
doesn't really sound like Mike or Walt
plus Breaking Bad made it pretty obvious
that the two men are dead if you'll
recall on the breaking bad episode
gliding over all Mike's body can be seen
in the trunk of Walt's
and Walt says that it was necessary for
him to shoot Mike I don't want to talk
about this okay it had to be done and on
the series finale Walt suffered gunshot
wounds in a shootout with Jack's white
supremacist gang ultimately succumbing
to his injuries on the floor of a meth
lab though it is worth noting that we
didn't see a body bag so there is a
chance that Walter survived the carnage
that considered it's possible that the
El Camino trailer is purposefully
misdirecting us the voice we hear in the
last few seconds may very well belong to
a random person and could have been
dubbed in during post-production to
throw fans off catching their attention
and sparking speculation without
revealing the true identity of the man
jesse was talking to this type of
trickery is not of all uncommon movie
trailers lied to us all the time and
would be a smart move to make when it
comes to the highly anticipated El
Camino of course with Breaking Bad
creator Vince Gilligan having revealed
that El Camino features more than 10
characters from the beloved drama series
there is also a chance that the mystery
man is someone were just not thinking of
yet
whomever Jesse Pinkman was seen talking
to in the final moments at the El Camino
trailer one thing seems obvious jesse is
about to embark on the mission and the
mystery man is involved in some capacity
all that we can do for now is wait
patiently for the much-anticipated film
to answer all of our burning questions
when it premieres on Netflix on October
11 check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stop or coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]